WITH THE WAY, THE WAVE OF
MIGRANTS AND MIGRANT MINERS THAT
HAVE MADE THIS A RECORD-SETTING
YEAR AT THE BORDER.
CHAD WOLF IS ACTING DHS
SECRETARY WHO JOINS US NOW.
THE GOVERNOR WILL OUTLINE HOW TO
UTILIZE THOSE TROOPS FROM ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY THE GOVERNORS
ARE SENDING TO THE BORDER BUT WE
HAVEN’T GOTTEN WORD FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT WHAT
HE’S DOING IS LEGAL.
I SUSPECT THEY ARE NOT FOR WHAT
HE IS DOING SINCE SO MUCH OF THE
LAND IS FEDERAL LAND.
WHERE IS THIS GOING?
>> WHAT GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS DOING
IS PROTECTING COMMUNITIES IN
TEXAS TO BE SURE THERE IS PROPER
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO KEEP
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS OUT OF
TEXAS.
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS TO DO IS WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR INSTEAD OF BEING AN
ADVERSARY TO HIM.
ONCE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
GOVERNORS LIKE THE STATE OF
TEXAS, STATE OF ARIZONA WORK
TOGETHER THEY CAN SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BUT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CHOOSES NOT TO
ENFORCE BORDER SECURITY LAWS AND
BUILD THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BORDER PATROL
NEEDS AND GOVERNORS ARE FORCED
TO DO THIS ON THEIR OWN.
NEIL: I TRIED TO KEEP THE
POLITICS OUT OF THE LEFT OR
RIGHT BUT YOU HEAR FROM THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THIS IS
BEING SENSATIONALIZED, THINGS
ARE NOT AS DIRE AS MEDIA
REPORTS, NAMELY FOX, REPORTED,
SEEM TO BE THE ONLY ONE
REPORTING WHAT IS GOING ON BUT I
SEE THE NUMBERS OF 3 DAY.
I GET STATS FROM ALL THESE
BORDER PATROL AND OTHER
OFFICIALS AND THEY ARE WHAT THEY
ARE, THEY ARE RECORDS, DOWN FROM
WHERE WE WERE A FEW WEEKS AGO
BUT NOT BY MUCH, YEAR OVER YEAR,
UP SIGNIFICANTLY, CLOSE TO 45%.
THAT BEING THE CASE CAN THE
ADMINISTRATION BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY IF IT SAYS IT IS
LOOKING FOR A SERIOUS SOLUTION
IF IT DOESN’T SEE THE PROBLEM?
>> THE ADMINISTRATION HAS A
CREDIBILITY PROBLEM IN A TALK
ABOUT THE BORDER AND THEIR
EFFORTS ALONG THERE.
WE SEE NUMBERS AT HISTORIC
CRISIS AND EVEN THOUGH IT MAY
NOT BE IN THE NEWS EVERY DAY AND
OTHER NETWORKS ARE NOT COVERING
IT THEY ARE BREAKING THE SYSTEM
AT THE BORDER, NOT ENOUGH
INFRASTRUCTURE, NOT ENOUGH
FACILITIES, NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
PROCESS THE INDIVIDUALS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER ILLEGALLY
EVERY DAY AND EVERY MONTH, THE
NUMBERS IN JUNE WILL BE HIGHER
THAN THE NUMBERS IN MAY SO YOU
CONTINUE TO SEE HISTORIC
NUMBERS, NOT JUST ABOUT MIGRANTS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER BUT
CARTELS, SMUGGLERS AND THE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT COMES
WITH THAT.
WE NEED TO GET SERIOUS.
IT IS A REAL ISSUE ALONG THE
BORDER BUT A REAL ISSUE FOR ALL
AMERICAN CITIES SEEING ILLEGAL
NARCOTICS AND MIGRANTS SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE, BORDER SECURITY IS
NATIONAL SECURITY.
I CAN’T EMPHASIZE ENOUGH THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY ENOUGH AND THEY NEED
TO CONTINUE TO PUT AMERICANS
FIRST AS THEY LOOK POLICY TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
NEIL: THANK YOU FOR THAT,
SHOWING THESE OUTDOOR FACILITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN CONSTRUCTED TO
DEAL WITH WAVE AFTER WAVE OF